beyonce and jay-z enjoy a rare date
night out in new york on saturday a
source tells e.t the couple had dinner
at hudson clearwater in the west village
it was so much fun the source also adds
quote they looked really happy and super
relaxed it was also a kid-free evening
so that might be why following dinner
jay and b attended the coldplay concert
at metlife stadium i was so excited
coldplay frontman chris martin even
dedicated the band's hit song with bts
my universe
[Music]
to quote sean and bibi sean being jay's
birth name and bb a nickname for queen b
jay-z and beyonce recently celebrated
their 14th wedding anniversary in april
and beyonce's mom tina knowles lawson
took to instagram with a sweet tribute
for her daughter and son-in-law
i don't have a reason
to cry
[Music]
the couple married in 2008 and have
since welcomed three kiddos blue ivy in
2012 and twins roomie and sir in 2017.
[Music]
yeah that's the couple's 10 year old
daughter blue crashing their date night
in a romantic clip for tiffany's
[Music]
blue isn't their only daughter getting
in on the family fun
it's so good
beyonce gave fans a rare glimpse of
blue's younger sister four-year-old
roomie in a campaign for ivy park in
november what's the best thing about
being a mom so far it's just i have such
a full life i feel like now i know the
reason why i was born and while the
carter ladies have been having fun
promoting their mom's fashion line their
dad well he's been busy too e.t spoke
with jay-z at the 18th anniversary of
his 40-40 club with fanatics and being
the first black applicant in new york to
apply for gaming
new york city's big thing obviously a
kid from brooklyn you know so it's big
for us very exciting and he also
explained why he loves working with his
wife she's a
super um
detail oriented obviously as you can see
from her work and she's a incredibly
hard worker
super talented
very inspiring
[Music]
you